I know hello everyone welcome miss
simulation I'm your host Don socket and
today we have the pleasure of sitting
down with Paul Shapiro it's my pleasure
Alan boom boom yeah baby this is gonna
be a lot of fun Paul Shapiro is
definitely one of the global leaders in
a really important movement something
that we do three times a day we eat food
and clean meat this is gonna be a good
in-depth conversation about that we'll
talk about other things like clean
leather other sustainable products and
how we're moving away from using animals
for its above post animal Bioeconomy
nice identity with a lingo like a Talon
Ryan Bethencourt top you know good yes
yes very good well you've been well
taught already you have a great master
with you right with Ryan
exactly exactly Paul Shapiro founded
compassion over killing and then he was
a vice president at the Humane Society
of the United States and now he's the
author of clean meat and this is an
amazing book this book will walk you
down and up all over the industry where
it's been where it's going and some of
the coolest parts about it used to cost
you know three billion bucks to get a
genome sequence now it's down to a
couple thousand it used to cost three
billion dollars to make an iPhone now it
costs just a couple hundred same thing
with clean meat now used to cost
millions of dollars now we're down to
hopefully by 2020 just ten bucks for a
nice big clean meat burger
what overall that would be huh we're
getting there yeah so Paul walk us
through you know you you're deaf you
went through the industry all over you
know the book walks you down all over
the industry and you've been in it for
so long
take us down this journey and what
you've learned and the significance of
it for study sure so it's a very nascent
field I mean the first company that was
ever founded for the sole purpose of
commercializing clean meat
Memphis meets just two years ago so we
are still in the infancy of this
industry but it's an idea that's been
around for a long time in fact even
going back to 1931 you had Winston
Churchill writing this essay predicting
what the world would look like in 50
years time and one of the predictions he
had was that we would escape the
absurdity of raising whole animals
rather than just growing the meat that
we actually wanted so now Churchill
looks to have been a few decades off but
his actual prophecy remains very
important and what was one science
fiction is now science fact with a slew
of companies being founded in the last
couple years racing to commercialize the
world's first-ever meat and other animal
products that are grown without animals
now think about the importance of that
because for millennia the only way that
we have had me it has been from animals
bodies yes we have alternatives to meat
but the only way to have real meat has
been from slaughtering animals now we're
on the verge of divorcing meat
production from livestock raising with
enormous benefits being associated with
it one you have the obvious benefit to
the animals that you can avert an
enormous amount of animal cruelty to you
have huge food safety benefits because
think about the so think about the food
safety benefits right now you have a
plague in the meat industry of E coli
salmonella Campylobacter
these are intestinal pathogens but with
clean meat when you're growing the meat
you're just growing the muscle you're
not growing intestines at all so you
don't have to worry so much about those
type of intestinal pathogens in fact
right now we're warned to treat raw meat
almost like toxic waste in our kitchen
why because it's riddled with theses
when you have a coli you have to cook
the crap out of your meat literally
you're literally cooking the crap out of
it to make it safe for you to consume
but with Queen meat you've huge food
safety advantages on that sense and then
also its Queen meat because it's like
clean energy it's much cleaner than the
conventional way that we've been getting
meat in the past
far fewer resources needed in fact one
study out of Oxford had found that to
produce Queen beef compared to
conventional beef you're talking about
99 percent less land 96 percent fewer
greenhouse gas
and over 90% less water use as well so
there's a whole host of reasons that we
want to do this yes so the first major
one is that the ethical the ethics
around slaughtering other beings of the
contentious beings animals and then the
second one is the pure cleanliness and
neljä the disease is that yeah I totally
agree handling eat in the kitchen all
that kind of stuff cooked in the crap
under that yeah and then thirdly is just
a whole slew of yeah you're right the
water savings greenhouse gas savings
right I mean think about it the planet
is not getting any bigger but humanity's
footprint on it is right now we have
seven and a half billion of us walking
around and by 2050 we're likely to add a
couple more billion how are we gonna
feed all of us I mean right now meat
consumption on a per capita basis is
like this not like this and I wish it
would go down we would be better off for
Public Health for environment for animal
welfare all types of reasons why we want
to reduce meat consumption but in the
areas that have the fastest population
growth they tend to also have the
highest growth of demand for meat as
well and so if we want to be able to
feed humanity the meat that people seem
to one in the coming decades we're gonna
have to get a lot more efficient about
how we produce it and growing meat as
opposed to raising and slaughtering
animals is one way to do that
I like how you called it divorcing
that's that's a really good way to
understand it divorcing it from the
animal completely but still eating meat
yes in fact I've joked before that you
might see in the future environmental
groups having slogans that say things
like eat meat not animals and you think
about it like this so 150 years ago the
only way that we had to get ice was
naturally formed ice that we harvested
from lakes and would ship it all around
the world that was it for millennia the
only way any human ever had ice was ice
those formed in nature then enter the
advent of industrial refrigeration now
all of a sudden you have a much cheaper
and more efficient way to get ice just
by cooling the water down right
and the natural ice industry was livid
over this innovation they were railed
against what they called artificial ice
saying that it was unsafe it was
unnatural you didn't want to put that in
your dream because you weren't sure if
it was gonna stick in you when the irony
at the time was that actually the
so-called artificial ice was much safer
because you didn't have to worry about
pollution in the water
or they were taking ice using horses who
were dragging it out of their lakes and
you know it's night courses are holding
it in while they're taking this ice out
of the way whereas when you're filtering
the water and then you are boiling it
and then freezing it it's much safer too
but the end result is still ice it's the
same exact product and that's just
that's what is clean meat is like the
end result it's just meat
it's safer and cleaner but it is just
meat it's not an alternative to meat
it's not some type of substitute for me
it is actual meat so and instead of
being taken from nature it is being used
as being done through a scientific
innovation in the same way that we have
ice today now we all have artificial ice
makers in our homes we call them
freezers when there's anything unnatural
about at all in fact you probably
wouldn't even consider using ice that
have been naturally formed in a wake I
mean I wouldn't need it would you
possibly do yeah maybe up north the
Greenland up and just yeah but what
about like New York where from probably
not from Central Park somewhere yes
exactly but yeah that's a good that's
really good comparison there's so many
other really good analogies like that
let's dive into what you said earlier
because this is crucial a lot of people
are starting to eat like the United
States does and that has become people
especially the Asian countries that
typically consumed more grains who's
starting to consume more meat and this
is this isn't even the population
including the population boom that we
are about to see it out of Africa in the
next 10 20 years
so the developing world is going to want
to consume meat and to be able to
produce it sustainably in bioreactors
sustainable safely
environmentally friendly with less water
less energy this is a crucial
advancement it's coming right at the
right time kind of yes yeah I think
you're right Alan and I would go so far
as to say that in the same way that in
many sub-saharan African countries have
they skipped over the the landline phase
of telephone communication they went
straight to cellular communication so
now lots of people in Africa have cell
phones and they never had landlines you
don't see those wires criss crossing to
every single home yeah in the same way
that cellular phone technology
revolutionized communication on the
African continent cellular agriculture
technology may do the same where instead
of having huge amounts of corn and soy
being grown to feed all these farm
animals and massive slaughter plants to
then and farms you then would just have
basically your own localized clean meat
production where you would have you
could even envision artisanal clean
meats being made with local operators
doing their own types of clean meat and
I think that you would have a revolution
in food and nutrition production yeah in
the same way that you did with
Communications I was so shocked when I
heard about that I can have my own
little micro brewery what did you call
it a carnivore II a car and a car nary a
card yeah man it's possible so think
about it this way so right now it's not
remarkable for somebody to come over to
your home and see that you have an
ice-cream maker or a bread maker well
what if you had a meat maker yeah what
if you could order little tea bags of
stem cells and drop them in and produce
your own meat and in fact one Japanese
clean meat startup has a project what
they call the shogen meat start of the
shogen meat project and they're already
giving Tokyo high school students
microwaves sized meat makers that they
take home and can grow their own meat in
these little Baker's now they're not
producing meat that you would think is
that delicious is kind of like blobs of
meat it's like very pretty typical yeah
but you can see if in 2018 they're
already doing that what might be
happening in let's say 2028
yeah so let's talk about the science how
it's actually occurring just from a very
10,000 foot view sir so yeah so how do
we actually take and grow clean meat
so imagine right now that if you burn
your right arm by accident you can take
a tiny little biopsy from the skin on
your left arm and we can grow your skin
not just human skin Allan's actual skin
genetically identical to your skin
because it is your skin and then put it
in the wound on your other arm and your
body accepts it because it's your skin
in the same way we could do that with
your muscle and that's what people eat
not necessarily homo sapiens muscle when
they do eat a lot of cow and chicken
muscle and fish muscle and so on so
here's how it works imagine taking a
very tiny sesame seed sized bot biopsy
from a cow and inside of that tunnel or
biopsy there are millions of cells that
are called satellite cells the only path
for their careers ever will be to
produce muscle they are the cells that
go to work when you do a hard workout or
you get injured they go and repair the
damage that is done and they create more
muscle so the only thing they can ever
do is become more muscle you take those
cells put them in a cultivator so they
think they're still in the animal's body
same temperature you've give them the
same type of food that would be eating
on the body and they do just what they
would be doing in the body except
outside of it which is produce muscle so
in a very real way what we're doing is
growing real muscle outside of the
animals body that is the same exact food
that would be inside except just done in
a sterile far safer environment and with
far fewer resources to produce that same
amount of meat and so then that's the
option where we take the small biopsy
from muscle biopsy and then let's
quickly talk about how what what are
what are the nutrients what's the
environment like for it to actually be
able to grow into a large amount of that
muscle biopsy
well what how quickly yeah as well so
you can depends on how much space you
have but you can do this within weeks
but one of the cool things is so you
want it to be the same temperature
as the animal's body what that means is
so you have to use some energy of course
to keep it at whatever body temperature
that species has but with cold blooded
animals like fish that means you need
far less energy because you don't need
so much heat to keep them warm so it's
actually far more efficient to grow
clean fish in the muds a queen pork or
beef but wait those run out closer to
human closer yeah yeah because mammals
are warm-blooded yeah and so she's like
40 Fahrenheit or I don't know the exact
but it's probably around that okay cool
it's probably not that different yeah
what your situate less energy for a fish
that's right yeah that's right however
you have to feed them and for the last
130 years that we've been culturing
cells a typical feed for the cells has
been was called some type of animal
serum whether it's a bovine fetal serum
which is particularly gnarly in terms of
how they get it and you're talking about
a Beatle calf who at the slaughter plant
just taken out of the dead mother and
then you extract serum from that
animal's heart so not exactly one the
most ethical thing but - it's also
extremely expensive when you're talking
about like $500 per liter of this fetal
bovine serum so in the medical space
they've not been concerned about the
cost because people pay a lot of money
for medical therapies but in the food
application space people are not willing
to pay a lot of money for food so while
Queen meat is generally borrowing
techniques from the medical space they
need to innovate and bring the cost way
down and feed the cells something else
that is not only more ethical but also
far far more economical so companies
like Hampton Creek or what's called just
or Memphis meats and others have been
experimenting with ways that they can
feed the cells usually plant-based
ingredients that will keep the cells
happy and proliferating while at the
same time being very economical and in
fact Nick Genovese II who is lead
scientist at Memphis meats published in
the journal Nature his own recipe for a
serum free serum free feed for the cells
and what do you know what that was a lot
of it is synthetic
however it's still too expensive I mean
you still have to keep getting it down
but it's moving in the right direction
and if you look at all of the money that
has been spent on Queen meat research
you're talking about merely tens of
millions of dollars I mean virtually
nothing compared to what the need is and
so in the future hopefully in coming
years you'll see hundreds of millions of
dollars worth putting being put into R&D
to create this new industry the good
news is that many of the big meat giants
like Tyson Foods and Cargill are now
invested in Memphis meats and so they
can help them with this yeah and so then
it also in that it's great to have
organizations like Cargill and Tyson's
this massive Giants getting involved
Branson and gates getting involved yeah
good stuff and you're a just the
beginning with tens of millions versus
hundreds and even billions of dollars
and that's when it's gonna be everywhere
easy fast safe all that good stuff so
when you take the the small wouldn't
take the small muscle biopsy and then
you feed it what's needed I will I've
really enjoyed understanding the
exponential growth of cell division yeah
because then it actually ends up growing
really quickly into the amount that you
need yeah yeah you can grow it much
faster than you could if you are raising
an animal I mean a cow you don't
slaughter for like one or two years
depending on a variety of factors with
this within weeks you can have the meat
and you're right what starts out with
one cell division a day and a half later
you are now starting to see that
exponential growth and so once you get
the process going and actually takes
less time to produce more meat than it
did at the very beginning about 30 days
to double every single one turns to two
four four eight oh it's my cells yes
much less than that these cells are
dividing often like every 30 hours
nicely days yeah oh I'm sorry I
apologize
yes to one and a half days exactly
between right I'm cell divisions which
is amazing right it's an exponential
right so the big problem or one of the
problems these companies face now though
is that they're able to produce ground
meat to think like chicken nuggets hot
dogs hamburgers sausage they're not able
to produce a chicken breast or a sirloin
steak because those thick cuts of meat
inside the animal's body there are blood
vessels and the blood vessels bring
nutrients to the cells whereas if you
try to do that in clean meat production
today the cells on the inside
go necrotic because they don't have any
way to bring the nutrients into them and
so the real key is to figure out how can
these companies replicate blood vessels
in the meat maybe they can use
microbeads that bring nutrients in
between the cells or maybe there's
something else they can do frankly
they're not really sure how they're
going to do it but for now ground meat
is still a huge portion of the meat that
we eat and then that just means that we
won't be able to get this exact form
formula for maybe the what looks like a
breast as soon as possible as I ground
meat is much easier to make it doesn't
need this breast shape form yeah or
steak shaped form that's exactly right
theoretically they can do it it's just a
matter of actually putting into practice
and nobody has done that yet and then
what are the alternatives as well to
taking the muscle biopsy because you had
a set a cellular agriculture so
impressive I'm not just a beginner level
okay so there's two different types of
clean animal product production there is
cellular agriculture which is where you
have the division of cells that are
producing this muscle then you have
what's called a cellular agriculture
where you have cells that are producing
the molecules that you want so let me
give you an example right now if you
take baker's yeast and you add sugar to
it then you produce co2 to make your
bread rise if you take brewers yeast you
add sugar to it and you'll get alcohol
as a by-product there are now certain
types of design or yeast
that company is like perfect day and gel
tour excuse me and Clara foods are using
where you feed them the sugar and what
they produce is dairy proteins or egg
proteins or collagen which is what you
can make gelatin from so you can design
the yeast that's right to make with
Claire foods egg whites yeah egg white
proteins that's exactly right yeah so
interestingly enough perfect day which
is a dairy platform company just brought
in 25 million dollars in their series a
to do just that what they're making or
real dairy proteins whey and casein and
other dairy proteins and what they do is
they take the yeast that they've
designed in feed it sugar and it
produces those proteins so it's not a
dairy alternative it is literally
actually dairy proteins and you never
had any cow not even a biopsy from a cow
you said oh yeah you're getting I mean
it's almost like you know why why buy
the cow when you can get the milk for
free right well why buy the cow when you
get the yeast to produce the milk Lori
and so the yeast doesn't remain in the
final product they put it in a
centrifuge so it you just have the pure
dairy proteins it's not like beer where
the yeast remains in so you don't have
any of the yeast in there that product
is still labeled GMO free but it is a
real dairy protein or real egg white
proteins or in the case of gel tour
which is a really cool company they're
making real gelatin without animals in
fact for this book clean meat they even
made the world's first-ever book bound
in clean leather so they created real
leather
Cal free of course through their process
and bound one copy of this book in lab
gran leather and we put it up on eBay
for the world's first Liberian leather
bound book ever and one lucky bidder
prevailed and got it for 13 grand and
now has it on his shelf at him that's so
nice and that that's one of many a I
just can't get over this like designing
yeast
not even use the animal acellular yeah
agriculture and then okay so let's
wander down the the leather conversation
we have gel tour we have mono meadow a
modern meadow Mike Michael works except
yes so they're doing different things
different ways to do it so yeah yeah
well Michael works is a really cool
company they are making they're making
alternatives to weather from mushrooms
and their products are amazing you look
at them they're truly incredible but
there are an alternative to whether it's
not actual animal collagen that is being
used modern meadow and gel tour for that
matter and another company called vitro
labs or making actual leather that they
are growing without any animals at all
and modern meadow is the best
capitalized of any of these companies
they've brought in over fifty million
dollars in investments so far and they
started out as a meat and leather
company and now have shifted to just
focusing on leather and here's the
here's the theory wide so the CEO Andres
floor GOx great guy his argument is
basically this one it's a lot easier to
produce this leather than it is to
produce me so he would like to do it for
that reason
leather you know it's a really a
two-dimensional product it's the skin
whereas meat is three-dimensional more
difficult to do those other in tastes
every single day yes that's right his
other argument though is they thinks
that people are more likely to wear
novel materials and to eat novel foods
and that if you can get people
accustomed to the idea of eating or
excuse me of wearing lab green leather
will they then be more accustomed to the
idea once clean meat hits the market and
so thing I know right now nobody thinks
twice about putting gore-tex on or
squeezing carbon fiber or other novel
human-made materials we don't even think
twice in fact we think they're awesome
we're like you serious like a thin thing
that it's comfortable and still keeps me
warm like that's great we have companies
now that are doing things like making
spider silk yeah this is a cellular
process like a bolt and spy burr and so
on and they're making really strong
threads that are the same as spider silk
but through the same else a cellular
agriculture process modern meadow is
going to be within the year 2018 putting
some real clean leather on the
they call it ZOA coa and the ZOA i've
looked at it in hell of it and I mean
it's leather it's it's it functions like
whether in fact it is superior
functionality you can make it as thick
or as thin as you want it you can make
it any shape you know Cal's very
stubborn lean do not come in the size of
wallets and wristwatches and car seats
but so there's a lot of waste in the
weather industry because they're cutting
it into forms that you have waist
leather also the cows might have scars
or insect bites or branding marks on
them that can make it but when you're
growing in the lab it's just pristine
exactly so the huge functionality
benefits to the process that companies
like modern meadow are using yeah I
remember feeling the one that Michael
works made and I just couldn't tell the
difference yeah I loved it yeah that was
so cool and that's through mycelium
grown but through mushrooms right on
versus grown from the Vienna the yeast
you know just grow I wouldn't think how
do they design a protein oh design the
yeast to be able to grow grow dairy
proteins and leather proteins
I'll tell you a story Allen that I think
is maybe the coolest thing that I have
seen so cool when humanity first arrived
on in the North American continent we
found a continent filled with lots of
what are called megafauna right these
huge animals including the Mastodon
well the Macedon didn't evolve around
humans and so is very little match for
us and within a few short millennia they
were extinct but some of them still
remain today locked away in icy graves
and we have uncovered them and yes they
were you know died off around ten eleven
thousand years ago but as with a lot of
animals who you find who have been
locked in ice for a long time if there's
any protein left to be found on them
it's probably collagen that will be
found and so using collagen that we've
taken from mastodons who we found today
we have mapped their their genome
anybody can go online and go get the
message on genome online so gel tour
went online got it and then ordered DNA
which had the Macedon genome encoded
in it and then using that produce real
Mastodon gelatin and then made their own
gummy candies now they didn't make gummy
bears they got elephant molds had made
real gummy elephant molds with Mastodon
gelatin and ate it this is the first
time any human has consumed Mastodon
protein in like over 10,000 years the
only this probably the only truly Paleo
diet and they're eating literally what
people on the Paleo I think era ate the
Mastodon and they did it I mean it's
incredible to think that in the 21st
century
they almost resurrected the Mastodon now
we don't have them lumbering around but
they really have resurrected the part of
a mastodon and then ate it first ones
and yeah it's a little ignoble that you
think like we bring them back just to
give you already was not lost on me I
trust me but that's so cool that we're
at that point of figuring things out
now let's chat quick about the you were
talking about the sustainability of the
savings in water the savings in land
savings and carbon emissions methane
emissions so what I mean you visited a
lot of places and I don't think many
people know what slaughterhouses
actually look like yeah and I think
that's a big life changer once you
experience that dimension of reality I
was lucky enough to go as well in high
school to slaughterhouse and it
definitely changed my life forever numb
so and there's a lot of practices there
that are not that are inhumane and so
maybe maybe walk us down just like an
understanding of what actually goes on
behind the scenes sure why that's
important to understand yeah I think you
know so often people will say something
oh it just seems like unnatural and grow
me without animals and I ask them well
have you thought about how we produce
meat today and just take chicken as one
example
I mean nearly all of the chicken meat
consumed in the u.s. come
from birds who are genetically
manipulated to grow so big so fast that
many of them couldn't even take more
than a few steps before collapsing
underneath their own weight
they lived wing to win in their own
feces they never went outside never
stepped foot on a blade of grass they
never saw the Sun and then by the time
over there pumped full of drugs like
antibiotics yeah and then by the time
they reached the slaughter plant most
people say stop I don't want to hear
about it because it's very difficult to
even listen to descriptions of violence
against animals let alone to witness it
yourself how many of us would like to go
and watch the birds be hung upside down
and have their throats slit and be
submerged in vats of electrified water
and that's the standard practice that's
definitely not the exception
I mean animal cruelty is the rule not
the exception in today's meat industry
and so when we think about just how
unnatural and inhuman yeah unsustainable
our current methods of meat production
are clean meat all of a sudden seems far
preferable and you know think about the
way that clean meat will be produced
it's not even really done in a lab we
think oh it's lab grand meat this really
inaccurate it's really in a brewery type
setting where this will occur I mean
always get your beer yes yeah exactly
and so all that you know you think about
I mean I've been in food companies where
they had R&D labs for peanut butter but
nobody calls that lab grand peanut
butter yeah you know I've been you know
everything from corn flakes to every
product that we're eating this process
started in a lab but then it gets moved
into a factory or brewery typesetting
and it's produced for us to consume and
the same is so here we'll have breweries
again maybe called Connery's and you can
envision them being even localized like
every neighborhood having their owner
clean meet brewery perhaps and you can
envision them being much closer to an
urban environment because nobody wants a
slaughterhouse near them who wants to
open your a slaughterhouse no nobody
does but it was actually pretty cool so
is that the Karner you know yeah install
the different ways that the clean meats
being made and yeah and yeah and these
companies these companies like just and
like Memphis meats envision having
literal glass walls now you just try to
get a tour of a slaughter plant most
people want even if they could get in
wouldn't
- but they probably you're gonna have a
difficult time even getting in yeah and
the Queen meat purveyors though are
psyched to have people come they want
them to come and see how it's doing this
is an industry that believes in radical
transparency because they think that
when people see how their meat is being
made they're gonna be even more
enthusiastic about eating it yeah the
the transparency the glass walls that's
that's a that's a crucial part again the
the Karner e that that's an exciting
aspect of the experience you you you you
asked the question at the beginning
after I asked you the question which was
you know where does your meat come from
or where does your food come from and
just that question in itself I think is
a very simulation esque question to ask
people it's kind of like one of our
theme thoughts that we have that we try
and share with people that watch the
show is really go down the chain of
events that get you to the point where
you're at or where someone's at when
you're having conversation with someone
and maybe there's there's a little bit
of dissonance you guys disagree on
something you know go down the chain of
events what is their life journey ask
them about it what led them to the
opinion that they have same thing with
the meat as well where did the meat
actually come from walk down the whole
chain of the animal being race and then
what actually happened until that point
right understanding the chain of events
that lead up to a certain thing is just
a really important way to expand your
mind to those new dimensions yeah I'm
totally with you Alan and in my
experience the more people do that the
more they learn about how meat is
actually produced the West's comfortable
they are that's a pretty good litmus
test for exactly the more you learn the
less comfortable you are it's probably
time to start rethinking our behavior I
mean for me you know I decided a long
time ago like we don't have to kill
animals so we really can survive just
fine on a plant-based diet it's healthy
it's good for the planet it's good for
us I'm happy to eat plants a lot of
people aren't a lot of people want to
eat meat and I think Queen meat and
plant-based means two are a great
solution to satiate that craving yeah
but when I first learned
about how cruelty is endemic in the meat
industry and how animals are subjected
to practices that are snowing humane
that they would be criminal if the
victims were dogs or cats I mean exactly
you know just think about it right now
if a burglar came into your home and
found a nice painting of a pig on your
wall and smashed that painting he could
get a greater sentence for destroying
your property then a pig farmer would
get for smashing up pig would who isn't
growing fast enough on his own farm I
mean the fact that you can get in
greater legal trouble for smashing a
painting of a pig than an actual pig
just speaks volumes about how little
legal protection farm animals have and
the fact that they have so what a legal
protection means that animal cruelty is
the norm now take what smashing is a
customary practice on pig farms for
animals who aren't growing fast enough
or who are sick but even more endemic is
a practice let's say like cutting their
genitals off of that painkiller yeah
which happens on a daily basis on these
places where pigs and and calves have
their testicles cut off without any pain
relief and if that were done to a dog
you'd be charged with felony animal
cruelty but the fact that victims are
pigs who feel pain with every bit as
much of intensity as dogs
it means it's a standard industry
practice now this is why we say that
people eat meat with their eyes squeezed
shut most people don't eat meat because
of how it is produced they eat meat in
spite of how it is produced and when
there is an alternative like Queen meat
available that can obviate all of these
types of concerns about animal cruelty
and so many other problems from food
safety to environmental and so on I
think people are going to be thrilled to
switch and they'll have a lot less
cognitive dissonance when thinking about
the types of things that we've just been
talking about yeah when you're in the
grocery store and you just see bacon but
the bacon didn't even come from
slaughtered Pig it just says bacon and
then you eat it and it tastes just like
the actual bacon does right and it's
completely clean meat and I think that
is absolutely a beautiful future that
we're heading to and yeah it's right
there in the grocery store are right
there at the
Carter II this from micro brewery from
your lips to the simulation creators
ears you know I hope that uh I hope
whoever created this simulation makes
that happen yeah we and we didn't touch
on this other one as well which i think
is important we have we have the small a
sesame-seed muscle biopsy version we
have the a cellular agricultural version
where it's brewed with the design with
yeast and brooded yeast and we get it
that way and then we have what is like
the beyond meat style what what is that
and sure yeah yeah let's talk about that
one yeah so beyond me which is a
fantastic company is using all plant
base there's no animal cells whatsoever
in their burgers or chicken or anything
but they have taken plant-based meats to
a new era so if you look for example at
the veggie burger evolve let's say ten
years ago it is just not on the same
planet as the Beyond burger of today and
one presumes ten years from now the
beyond burgers today are gonna be looked
back on similarly as archaic but for now
they're fantastic I mean they're so good
and so many people who eat them think
this tastes like meat it's not actual
meat it's much healthier for you it's
much better for the planet it's an
alternative to meat but it really does
look and taste like meat in the same way
for example that my belt is not actual
weather but it really does look look you
probably couldn't tell by what not at
all right here oh and so this is a non
leather belt that looks like whether the
beyond burger is a plant-based burger
that looks and tastes like a burger now
their main competitor it's a company
called impossible foods which also is a
very good plant-based burger but they
are using that same a cellular
technology to produce what's called heme
in their product so they argue at
impossible foods that heme is the magic
ingredient that mates and that makes
meat taste like meat it's this very you
know iron rich molecule that basically
helps to in a variety of ways for taste
and mouthfeel so the heme is produced by
impossible foods through a cellular
agriculture so that they are producing
real team that is the same as heme that
is in a burger but via microorganisms
and then they add that to their
plant-based burger and they assert that
it makes it taste much more meat like
I've had both of them many times I like
them both I think they're both very good
I have a preference for the beyond
burger but I have many friends who feel
opposite yeah and so good yeah they're
both excellent they really are but it's
interesting to see the blending of a
cellular technology is with plant-based
foods and I think that you're gonna see
that for the first products the first
clean meat products that come out it
would not surprise me at all if they
were blends if they were blends of
plant-based meat to keep the cost down
along with Queen meat so that you have
something that is actual animal muscle
and what are we typically using for the
plant-based meat right now well peas are
all the rage right now Peas yeah so psrp
protein is the big thing in the past it
has been a lot of soy or wheat protein
and that is still in some brands and I
like them I think they're very good but
P protein for a variety of reasons has
emerged currently as the winner let's
talk about why yeah well one there's a
little bit of a scare around soy I think
it's completely unfounded I think it's
it's a total myth and but people argue
about phytoestrogens in soy the evidence
is pretty clear that phytoestrogens
actually are quite healthy and they
suppress cancer so I think people are
doing themselves a real disservice by
not eating soy but there is that concern
then you also have the so-called scare
about wheat gluten free is all the rage
in some circles people believe that they
are sensitive to gluten it turns out
only about 1% of us actually have celiac
but maybe there are people who are
sensitive for some reason but the fact
that soy and wheat have these
connotations associated with them true
or false and the fact that they also are
common allergens has led to a real a
real rise in P protein because the P
protein one is very versatile it's
consider
this good queen protein it's not a
common allergen it's still inexpensive
enough it's not as cheap as soy or wheat
but it is still fairly inexpensive and
that's why you're seeing it used in so
many different products protein has
emerged on top for now but most plant
proteins have not even been sequenced I
mean it's this world that is open to us
that you know who knows
I mean Hampton Creek for example now is
making its just scramble out of mung
bean protein I saw it mung bean mung
beans among means very popular in Asia
people and their to eat lots of mung
beans people here probably never been
eaten among bein however mung bean
protein I saw it is so new in the United
States that they had to file with the
FDA just to get it approved as they
generally recognized as safe ingredient
which they did and you know it's just
Hmong means that's it it's just to take
the protein from among me and and you
put it in the food scramble just
scramble that's right
so the just scramble which the new just
product which they you can get at a
restaurant here in San Francisco now and
hopefully in cafeterias across the
country soon the primary ingredient is
mung bean protein so maybe we'll see
mung bean burgers in the in our future
oils yeah so okay so plant-based is also
exploding a cellulous exploding clean
meat grown for muscle biopsies exploding
this is awesome there's a bunch of
different ones that are you know
intertwining a bit and saving a lot of
agricultural variables that are going
into the growth factor environment water
sustainability with land all this good
stuff and we're going to be able to feed
the future generations that's the goal
yeah and the straight ethics this is
this might lead us into a couple small
simulation conversations but just within
the ethics this is always very
interesting to me to think about an
advanced civilization and what they do
with their beings that are less advanced
than they are interested what we do with
the beings that are less it yeah we are
so shouldn't we at least have some
ethical consideration for being because
we don't want even if our own
self-interest right
yeah I mean I actually think about this
quite often like how would an advanced
civilization treat us and the analogy
that folks have used like sam harris and
others that is seems particularly apt to
me i doubt that they would come here to
enslave and exploit us but i do think
they would be relatively indifferent to
our interests in the same way that we
don't consider an ant colony so right
now imagine there is an ant colony on
some land and we decide we want to build
a house there we don't we saw like we're
hostile toward ants we don't want to
harm it looks like we build the house to
harm the ends but we don't consider that
we've wiped out their civilization in
any way we just build the house without
even a second thought and I suspect that
an alien civilization might have a
similar they might be if they got here
that means they're very far advanced
from where we are technologically I
would imagine we would be the equivalent
to advanced to them that they you know
sonic they hate ants but they just don't
care that much about us I hope that if
they've gotten so far advanced and they
have some ethical right yeah and that's
Carl Sagan's argument that he thinks
that if you can make it through that
bottleneck of the growth of a
civilization that you must have some
level of empathy and compassion that you
can with it basically if you can make it
through that first phase of a
civilization without blowing yourself up
which we are kind of right now in that
phase yeah yeah we are I mean we are the
if this is so there are civilizations
out there they made it through the
bottleneck we are the new kid on the
block I mean we have only been able to
do anything outside of our planet for
such a short amount of time I mean like
that and you think about the other
civilizations if they are out there
presumably they have been doing it for
millennia or longer maybe millions of
years who knows and so I would hope that
they would have like some type of a rule
like the prime directive and Star Trek
how you know you basically don't
interfere or intervene or harm the
inhabitants of the cosmos as you're
traveling through yep
and in some senses we have that
at least in law so the UN has the outer
space treaty of 1967 and that requires
us to avoid harmful contamination of
celestial bodies and so at NASA they
actually have an office of
interplanetary protection right and that
office of interplanetary protection yes
it's to avoid harming ourselves I bring
you back some you know like an Andromeda
Strain type event but it's also to
protect them you know we when we go to
Mars we sterilize our Rovers and we
there's some instruments that are so
sensitive that we can't send them we
want to send them but we can't they
can't withstand the baking before we
send them to Mars and so we're harming
our in scientific efforts because of our
concern for contaminating Mars now you
could argue we're doing it because we
want to protect the integrity of our
scientific experiments up there we don't
want to discover life there just a
finding that we brought it there
ourselves
but we're also concerned about
preventing extinctions on Mars I mean
that is pursuing pretty noble to me that
we don't even know if life is there and
we are taking precautions to avoid
causing extinctions on Mars or other
places we may Land Rovers that to me it
seems like we ought to pat ourselves on
the back for that I mean we don't seem
that concerned about preventing
extinctions here on earth but at least
on Mars you know that's pretty good so
for a species that doesn't have a good
track record when it comes to causing
harm I would say that's a bright light
NASA's policy is a bright light and and
hopefully we can see more of that yeah
is is there a as we talk about Earth and
of the potential as extinction-level
events that occurred in this bottleneck
are you woody what are your thoughts
about the current state of maybe wealth
inequality a geopolitical fighting yeah
well I think we're closer to catastrophe
than we have been in a long time now I
do buy into the Steven Pinker argument
that things were better now than they
ever have been for humans at least and
he's pretty clear this isn't true for
animals and for for non-human animals
things are really worse than they've
ever been
so if you take the interests of other
species seriously considering that there
are tens of billions of them
individually you know it's sad so there
are a million chickens being slaughtered
in the US every hour right every hour
and these are I mean and point out that
their slaughter is the best day of their
lives it's the day the misery finally
comes to an end you know for most
animals on factory farms they can't I
mean their interests are best served in
that sense because they're being
tormented for so long that finally when
they're killed as violent and painful as
it is at least their suffering ends so I
mean I'm even more concerned I'm
concerned about the slaughter but I'm
more concerned about the months prior to
slaughter that they spend languish and
stressing the meat that we end up eating
totally taking on their stress yeah yeah
so anyway though to answer your question
directly I I think that there are real
concerns about nuclear war where you
have two people with nuclear arsenals
who I I don't think it would be that
unreasonable to be worried about what
they might do I mean absolutely you know
the leaders of the u.s. and North Korea
right now are in a in a showdown that I
think is probably among the most
important things that's happening and
yet you don't see it as much in the news
and we see lots of other important
things in the news but things that do
not pose existential risks to every
nation on the planet basically in fact
if you were to only have news that
focused on like the most important
things going on right now
you would see a lot of a lot of it
dominated by that nuclear threat I think
do you so you think nuclear is a very
big threat and absolutely it absolutely
is yeah what do you think about eight
people having as much wealth as the
bottom four billion yeah what do we do
about that
well far from me to be a pundit on
something I'm not an expert on clearly I
think it's a big problem I think it
poses severe instability risks where you
have such a dramatic disparity in wealth
and power in that sense but what I would
suggest I'll be even more concerned
about in terms of like actually
existential risk
would be having let's say eight people
who have the capacity to grow some type
of a virus in their basement like that
to me is another real risk as the the
gene-editing has become so democratized
and so inexpensive that people can do
things that only governments could do
before and when you have that capacity
even if it's just by accident even if
it's not somebody who is maliciously
doing it you have a real threat you know
look at the 1918 Spanish flu as an
example that killed between like 50 to
100 million people and that was in a
time before
well one there was only around a billion
people on the planet and two you didn't
have the type of global travel that we
have today yeah
imagine if another strain like that
naturally arose or if it arose
unnaturally through a human-made
virus again intentionally or
unintentionally that to me is a real
threat and nighttime is one of the
reasons why I am enthusiastic about the
work of agencies like ir po which is one
of the federal intelligence agencies
which is designed to try to prevent
those types of things from happening in
the future by predicting when they might
actually have yeah and there's an
interesting intersection because the guy
who runs ir pub was a guy named Jason
Matheny who spent the earlier portion of
his career being a clean meat prophet in
fact he founded he founded new harvest
which is a group that pollutes clean
meat and then he left the Queen meat or
because he was so concerned about
existential threats and now was running
the agency of AI ARPA to prevent these
type of civilizational e threatening
events like asteroid collisions or
viruses and so on yeah and you need to
something right there asteroid collision
virus and clear war there's so many of
them instability from wealth inequality
there's so many of these the things that
are going on right now that just we love
talking about with our guests because if
we can increase the amount of
conversations that occur about these
topics I think it will drive more action
yeah I hope yeah yeah you know because
we have lived in such a time of
abundance for us and where we live and
how we really struck the lottery like we
won the jackpot really yes in amazing
ways we get I think we get a little bit
complacent and we think this is how it
will always be because this is
it's been for our whole lives yeah and
we forget that our civilization it's
like that's like the veneer like imagine
that like food transportation stopped
for a few days what would happen I mean
the reversionary was stopped yeah right
it's a reversion to a tribal state would
be extremely quick yeah and so III think
like you know it's a good party while it
lasts
but I think we need to do everything
possible to make sure the lights don't
go out that's right yeah that's exactly
right that's exactly right yeah and
imagine if we have Queen meat and and
that happens and they're still with some
way to run those planets imagine the
flight that will be to keep the meat
churning as that in that sense exactly
are there other aspects about clean meat
that you want to discuss before we go
into simulation more simulation question
depth I would just suggest I think it's
among the single most pressing problems
that humanity faces right now is this
problem of animal agriculture agree it
is a leading cause of deforestation air
water soil pollution climate change and
so on so often when people who think
along the lines of the questions that
you're asking or thinking they're
thinking about the important questions
that we've just been addressing from
nuclear war to asteroids to viruses to
wealth inequality and so on but animal
agriculture belongs up there this is a
huge threat to us it is destroying the
planet in ways that few other things are
not nothing else I mean you know the
fossil fuels are obviously a huge
problem as well yeah but in the same way
that we have this race to produce clean
energy we need a race to produce clean
meat and there's billions of dollars
going into finding clean energy sources
and that isn't happening yet and clean
meat and it needs to be happening
very eloquently said thank you thank you
sir thank you
so I mean we're talking satellite views
of just afforestation and that and the
worth we're talking about emissions
methane emissions we're talking about
just vast swathes of animals that are
suffering throughout their lives and
then being slaughtered
there's I just you're absolutely right I
think you know one of the questions that
we asked on here is is clean meat a
viable source of food for our future and
it's I think it's an overwhelmingly like
yes it is and actually I found this very
interesting in pulse book you describe
how out of university level students out
of the pols is around 77 or so over
through to three-fourths actually would
probably or they would in I'm not you
read the book so closely Alan yes yeah
absolutely
that's the only way to learn and
highlight the important things and this
is so this is very much so moving into
kind of the you know our field of like
25 year olds and even further
moving into the field of the Jen's ears
that are growing up that are thinking to
themselves as well they're they're
learning about oh this is where it comes
from
you know there's a clean meat option oh
and it's becoming more and more I think
generational to be like oh we know the
clear answer here we're definitely down
to give it a go and figure yeah that's
really healthy and powerful I agree and
yeah there's definitely a generational
thing here going on so the the younger
you are the more likely you are to be
willing to try clean meat but even just
looking at all Americans regardless of
age a third of Americans in the latest
poll said they would regularly eat clean
me Wow and another third say they would
give it a try so at a bare minimum
you're talking about a multi-billion
dollar industry and you know what people
what we tell pollsters we would do what
we actually do I think are sometimes
quite different but it's still very
promising that people are willing to say
yeah I do
and the fact is like we're eating foods
that are the products of technology all
the time and with good reason
and that process started the very first
time somebody picked up a seed and
decided to plant it rather than
continuing to be a hunter-gatherer I
mean we've been modifying our foods for
so long now I mean if you think that
that the bananas that we were eating
before we started this interview
resemble in any way the bananas that
existed before we domesticated them
they're bigger they're sweeter they have
these little tiny seeds in them that
aren't they don't even recognize them as
seeds the original de bananas had huge
seeds in them and so you just think
about that and it's like this is the
natural extension of what we've been
doing for millennia basically they think
food better is seemingly more convenient
for us the taste here yeah yeah exactly
Ron what are your thoughts about clean
meat would you would you give it a go
no of course that would nice even though
I love I had that burger last night
before I went to bed and I was thinking
how I was failing you know this isn't
what I'm supposed to be doing in eating
yeah well right well I'm thinking about
it this way so I of course agree I think
you'd be better off getting a beyond
burger I think they're awesome I highly
recommend them they're only $2.99 a
burger at your local supermarket and
they're really good we need to get them
on our sponsorship bro all right no more
freebies for them however so often we
make choices as consumers that don't
align with our ethics because we do what
all people do which is revert to
convenience I mean I think about
clothing you know you go to let's say
Target and you see a t-shirt it's only 7
bucks you like them this is a good price
I'm gonna get this shirt you're not
thinking about like the kids in
Bangladesh we made that shirt and if you
did you probably wouldn't be that
comfortable with it but we just buy it
because it's the cheapest thing in fact
you might even vote to ban the sale of
such up produced goods if you could as a
citizen go vote on that question you'd
probably vote to ban it then with your
money right probably don't
we act very differently as consumers
than we do at citizens and cultural
programming in that sense it's very
interesting where we go with our money
yeah yeah I mean that's what we do I
mean that's what nearly all of us do I
see myself included when 99 percent of
the food options for meat are not clean
meat right you gotta go take a one-hour
more of your time half hour they're a
far back just to get that thing until it
proliferate Stu all grocery stores in
all restaurants yeah well the good news
is that you now have plant-based meats
in all grocery stores it's getting there
young there at least in the major chains
like Safeway and Kroger and so on and
you can try it like you said today to go
taste plant-based meats and and get a
little bit of that inspiration for what
is gonna be coming right around the
corner and the the Ronnie of thought I
love mushrooms I know that you could do
a lot with mushrooms a portobello
mushroom a big portobello mushroom is
like a tender steak yeah yeah it does
it's used as a burger the the portobello
mushroom tops used as a burger yeah I'm
actually for inventing many vegetable
burgers and mushrooms are also used for
structural material leather all this
yeah amazing stuff yeah in fact to bring
the beginning around you were talking
about our friend Ryan Bethencourt at the
top of this interview and Ryan has now
started his own company wild earth that
is from mycelium which are like the
roots and mushrooms making pet food yep
and so mushrooms are really versatile
it's it's pretty cool to think about not
just plant based but fungi based foods
and other other things you can make with
them yeah and you can see ways that we
can help save the planet through a whole
new realm of production it's really cool
I'm really happy that you expanded in my
mind to the new dimension of putting
animal agriculture into the same
category as the other major existential
conversational points valid that's
really important for me
to fully have grasped that importance
yeah so I mean one it's it's clearly
true I mean it is just I mean such a
driver of so many of the problems that
we face but at the same time lots of the
things that we put into that category of
some of the biggest problems that
humanity faces or things that an
individual can do very little about
there's very little you or I can do
about the nuclear showdown between
Donald Trump and Kim Jong Un's
yeah there is very little I can do about
preventing submaster yeah an asteroid or
a man man with a molecular biology lab
in his basement and so I theorized that
animal agriculture often is not in that
list simply because it produces more
cognitive dissonance on the others it's
very easy for us to say oh yes these are
problems that our leaders need to
address what our policymakers need to
address
whereas with animal agriculture you
don't point your finger outward I mean
yeah we do need our readers to address
it from their inward because we're
eating it every single day of our lives
yeah and so I think there's more
cognitive dissonance and it's harder to
grasp that we are part of the problem
but once we can allow ourselves the
ability to imagine a world in which
we're not so dependent on animal
agriculture it becomes easier to think
actually yeah this is a real problem
and it's similar in some respects
nothing I'm morally acquitting them but
just in terms of a comparison the
northern states in the u.s. were able to
ban slavery legislatively you didn't
require war to do it the reason is
because their economies were not so
dependent on slavery anymore because
they were industrializing it's not like
they were just morally superior their
economies had gone toward industrial and
so they didn't have this agriculture
economy that was based on Human Bondage
and so for them it was easier to develop
anti-slavery sentiment because there
wasn't as much cognitive dissonance if
you lived in the south though and your
economy depended on the enslavement of
people you would also income with all
types of rationalizations of their
inferior people this is what they're you
know I mean all types of things that you
would say to yourself to delude yourself
into thinking that slavery wasn't a
problem in many ways animal agriculture
is the basis for so many of our food and
clothing decisions today that it's hard
for us to rational to it's it's hard for
us to conceptualize that maybe there's
something wrong with it because we're so
dependent on it but in the same way that
once we stopped let's say whaling and
because we had kerosene we could all of
a sudden develop humane sentiment for
whales in the same way that once we no
longer depending on horses for our
transportation because we had a car now
horses our companion animals for the
most part they're not labour animals
four hours of the time and now I mean
the u.s. used to be the biggest whale
killing nation in the world now we're
among the biggest whale watching nations
this me and imagine telling somebody in
1850 that the big industry would be
people going out on boats to shoot
whales with cameras even what a camera
was but you know quick think about that
like I mean that we have people and
myself included were paid just to go
watch whales they would be baffled by
that thought but because we know that
whales are actually quite incredible
intelligent creatures who have its whole
societies down there with language and
songs and all that but if we were still
dependent on whales for lighting our
homes that would be very hard for us to
accept the scientific reality that the
whales are extremely intelligent yeah
and you bring up a really good analogy
as well with slavery as well once you
move away from the need of do you build
new technologies and new systems you can
give legislation purposes to say we no
longer need that put it away get it done
so suffering it's bad right over so
potentially once you get these car
Nuri's up and around and people are
eating me clean meat more you know the
the legislation might go through to
completely ban the use of of actual
animal product and that seems far off to
me but it doesn't I mean far in terms of
the distance however you know you never
know what's gonna happen I mean if you
had tomorrow night it's a brainer yeah
yeah I mean if you had told people
they're like 200 years ago that we were
going to view slavery and child labor as
abominations that the thought of women
being denied the right
that would be completely unethical in
anathema like you'd be laughed out of
town I mean you know the things that we
consider today as moral common sense are
things that would be so foreign to our
ancestors and so it's difficult for us
in 2018 to imagine that world but maybe
the world of 2118 it's not so hard to
imagine that exactly exactly and that's
that that's why we have these
conversations because when you expand
your mind to just 100 years back and
analyze and a hundred years forward and
analyze the present moment in great
timeline it doesn't even seem that far
off to really have legislation that says
that you plan forget about a hundred
years ago fifty years ago the legitimate
debate that was dividing our society was
whether whites and blacks ought to be
able to use the same water fountain yeah
that's what would there's a raucous
debate today if you were to take the
wrong side on that debate in your progra
Gatien you'd be socially ostracized you
you mean imagine posting on Facebook
that you were for racially segregated
water fountains you would be unfriended
you might even make news yeah I mean
just for espousing a view that 50 years
ago lots of people and respectable
positions of power in our society held
that very view yet today thankfully we
view that as totally morally a Tricia's
so 50 years from now things that were
held as quite normal views to hold
people might be in total revulsion over
them and you take slavery is just one
example I mean many of the smartest
people Socrates Aristotle thought
slavery was totally normal and natural I
mean every human civilization up until
recently for the most part you had I
mean from the Greeks to the Romans and
the Egyptians they all had slaves yeah
no I mean anti-slavery sentiment for the
most part as a mainstream phenomenon is
a relatively new thing maybe 150 years
or so um you know really going back to
the Enlightenment so a little bit more
than 150 years but that is something
that would have been a laughable view to
many people and now it's the widespread
view of probably you know at least nine
out of ten people and that this sort of
thinking is so important it's the
analysis of history and the analysis of
culture and how we use tools and systems
and then
present moment and analyzing where we
are now and thinking about the future
and where we want to go and this holds
this this Timeline view of it is really
important for expanding our minds to
these new ways of thinking because we
similarly with how we frown upon what we
thought 50 years ago was normal and now
it's like Acts you will get ostracized
the same thing today we don't even bat
an eye flash eyelid for this use of coal
and fossil fuels right 50 years down the
line you will not be able to dig into
the earth for any sort of use of oil or
or coal to power anything you will only
hopefully be able to use solar or fusion
or other forms of sustainable energy so
I love this sort of it's kind of like
the long now thinking really yeah it's
it's thinking about society on a 1,000
or 10,000 year timeline and how
important it is to have that sort of I
thought because if all of our minds get
expanded to the new dimension of long
now thinking then we think about
oh yeah 50 years down online we're
probably not going to be doing this so
it's like the companies eventually end
up the ones that may be racially
segregated are the ones that promote
slavery the ones that were anti women or
that work that were current that are
that are currently for fossil fuels or
yeah or even things like the high
fructose corn syrup even even these
companies that are currently for these
things that are not healthy for society
will one day and this is thanks to Stu's
immerman they will one day it turn from
the caterpillar into the butterfly they
won't
evolve and hopefully peacefully and
hopefully with less havoc yeah with
society to get to that point of being a
butterfly and then it will be without a
question what we live and use yeah uh
I'm with you and I think the key to
ensuring there's less havoc is to make
sure that those who are let's say the
purveyors of let's say meat products
today are able to get in on this clean
meat revolution Tyson a car jumped in
and that's exactly certain the fact that
Tyson and Cargill have invested in clean
meat is is really important there's a
whole variety of reasons I mean you want
to be as companies to be a part of the
future you don't want to fight with them
which will not only delay this future by
decades but also I think might even
prevent it or might have some type of
really serious problems I do want to
stress you know we're talking about all
of these progressions in society from
anti-slavery to women's suffrage to the
anti-segregation movement and so on and
it does at least have an implication
that there is somehow like a
self-executing way that this happens I
don't think that that's terrific that
yeah yeah I don't think you don't think
we awaken to higher states of
consciousness as we go culturally I hope
that that's true but I think there's
things that we can do to accelerate the
process know there's things that we can
do that decelerate the process yeah and
so normally like he's sure these
revolutions occur not just in a
self-executing manner they occur when
good people put in the hard work of
organizing to make them happen and
inspiring others yes a look at look for
example at the advancement of the debate
around gay rights in America I mean the
1990s civil unions was the pro-gay
position now it's the anti gay position
now you see the anti gay people all just
take civil unions well now marriage is
the Pro gay position in fact it's the
law of the land but just a few years ago
that wasn't the case and that didn't
happen because just magically people
became more sympathetic it happened
because there was a very effective gay
rights movement
with wonderful leadership and and like
soldiers in that movement so to speak
who helped push the issue further down
the line exactly and if they hadn't
maybe it would have still happened but
maybe decades later correct and so I
mean if you look like let's just say a
reconstruction like a reconstruction in
America had been allowed to conclude and
move on rather than having it ended you
might not have ever needed a civil
rights have been a hundred years later
so there are ways that we can accelerate
these progresses and slow them down as
well and so I just think we are making
great progress but it involves active
hard work on the part of those who want
to see that progress happening you're
100% right and we have the potential to
accelerate what we want to build into
the world and by putting together the
people and the actions and inspiring
others and even getting in some of these
sort of Caterpillar organism get
involved it for them to help turn them
into butterflies otherwise there could
be some combat there and that combat
would slow down the progress okay so
very I like how we're transitioning to a
very how does this variable of animal
agriculture play into existence on the
even the same scale as you know
geopolitics good question I wanted to
ask you this do you see a clean meat in
China and Russia and other Europe do we
see some of that going on in Brazil and
other places India etc yes so if you
look at the BRIC countries Brazil Russia
India China these are where there's huge
population growth emerging economies and
those are the places where I think clean
meat might end up being the most
important because you have a lot of
people and big demand and increase from
big increase in the demand for meat and
so a company like just for example
formerly Hampton Creek is now talking
about opening production plants in Asia
I mean they want to essentially have
Chinese production of their products
exactly which would be totally stunning
because there's so much need there in
fact one of their early investors was
lee kai-shing
billionaire and I think you're gonna see
a huge push toward these types of food
sustainability movements in China and in
fact in some major cities like Hong Kong
and Beijing and Shanghai you're now
seeing the proliferation of vegetarian
and vegan restaurants and foods and
grocery stores coming out yeah right now
like a decade or so er no no in the last
few years you know as humans good that
that's yes but it's very good are there
clean neat companies being formed in LA
yeah yeah so there are no clean meat
companies yet there there is a one in
Japan but it is the aspiration of
companies like just to produce clean me
to there they they are eagerly seeking
to do it and you know there's questions
very much so rooted in how like China is
so wanting to get forward in AI or yeah
genetic engineering and it's very
interesting to think about how the
United States and China will inter inter
play within the the progress of
globalization what actually occurs but
that's why I asked about clean meat are
they also invested into animal
agriculture and feeding out how to feed
the world is right yeah the Chinese are
very interested in in cellular
agriculture and clean meat in general
because they view it as a way to help
feed a growing population and so the
Chinese government has so far some
signals that it's interested in this in
fact it had a 300 million dollar deal
with clean for a clean tech a clean tech
deal with Israel that a lot of people
are hopeful will be moving some of the
Israeli clean meat companies into that
space and so yeah Israel is big you
there was a was it the world's first
clean meat conference the world's first
in Israel there have been other clean
meat conferences yes okay I didn't even
know that cleany conferences was a thing
oh yeah I love that yeah there's been a
couple here in San Francisco but what
are the names of the conference's
generally so new harvest is an
organization that doesn't they just call
it like new harvest conference the good
food Institute is this one was
oh cool and even going back to 2008 love
you Bruce and we love you Bruce
so the the good food Institute is doing
one upcoming but even going back a
decade ago in Norway in 2008 they had a
clean meat conference it wasn't called
clean meat back then in fact very
amusingly it was called the conference
for in-vitro meat and there was a New
York Times columnist who wrote about it
and he had a parenthetical comment
saying they might want to do something
about that name but so the idea of a
queen meat conferences is not
necessarily new but in Israel it was new
and they had this great conference in
Haifa where a lot of the leading
researchers came together and talked
about this and Israel is a hub of the
community industry in fact a major
german poultry company like a Tyson
Foods of Germany just invested in super
meat which is Israel's leading clean
meat company so now Israel's leading
queen meat companies millions of dollars
of investment directly from the meat
industry awesome yeah from from a German
poultry company country company Wow yeah
yeah it's very like tysonis yeah right
that's great it's happening around the
world then it's amazing awesome that's
that's kind of what I was hoping though
you know pull out something like that to
really show how we are working together
in that sense and there's even an
example of another major poultry company
around the world
yeah investing in clean meat Israel
that's so great I love it out that yes
so let's run you through okay as we talk
about the problems that our world's
facing these major ones what are your
thoughts about maximizing human
potential yeah how do we do that
well I don't think my thoughts are that
controversy are different from from
others I mean I you know I'm a fan of
many of the things that are popular in
this space so I'll give you one example
of what I think is one of the most
important things that we can do
providing education and family planning
to
women around the world who live in
developing countries is one of the most
important things that we can do at all
not only for so right now in places that
have really high fertility rates women
are basically burdened by having to
raise multiple kids and they don't want
that many kids they just don't have
access to contraceptives or culturally
they can't get them or for whatever
reasons they don't control their
reproductive destiny and by engaging in
lower or free low cost or free family
planning in and providing education for
young girls in developing countries
where oftentimes they don't get
education at all or if they do it's
dramatically inferior to what boys get
you can not only raise their standard of
living but also lower fertility rates so
that they don't they have the number of
kids they want to have as opposed to
having more kids and they want to have
which is a program for them and so I
think in terms of dollars spent one of
the most important things that we can do
is to focus on the plight of girls and
women in developing countries honestly
that's a really good one one that we
haven't hurt oh well it's awesome yeah
it's a it's an important way to wealth
to do everything that we just said yeah
and it does tie into the overall
conversation that we do have on the show
frequently about how to best raise a
child into the world and how the parent
is kind of the dog to the child yeah and
so if the parent is educated about these
practices that you discuss especially
about things like how to educate their
child about evolution or how to educate
them about their internal anatomy and
physiology or how about morality and
self-actualization how to make an impact
in the world and be fulfilled and the
one when these conversations are being
had we end up having like you're
describing a more well-rounded and
educated being come into our world when
they can teach their children the same
principles and stuff I think that's very
important and I would just even go like
just further say like the pathway to
escaping poverty is through lower
fertility and higher education
having lots of kids often times
sentences women to being in poverty and
to their children therefore being in
poverty us and if we can provide
education and family planning for those
who want it you know try to force it on
anybody but those who actually want it
you can do an enormous amount of good so
right now it's estimated there's
probably about 300 million women in the
world who don't have access to family
planning who want to have fewer children
think about that from their perspective
and then think about that from the
global perspective as well in an
overpopulated world already and so
providing them with the resources that
we take for granted like education and
family planning is one of the most cost
effective ways to improve human
potential and naturalize it I think
awesome and then what do you think is
the most beautiful thing in the world
God there are so many things of great
beauty but I think for me aside from my
wonderful partner Tony Okamoto probably
the most beautiful thing that I ever
look at is when I'm fortunate enough to
be in a dark enough sky somewhere
without light pollution and can look out
on the cosmos and see all of these other
stars out there and knowing that many of
them have their own planets circling
around them and that there are probably
beings on some of those planets and
thinking about them as really like our
interstellar brethren and sistren
so I think about how in my lifetime I
may never know them I may never be able
to communicate with them but I feel
quite confident that they're there and I
like to think that you know none of us
asked to be born we just arose not
through our own volition and we're in
this cold hostile gigantic universe that
maybe has some type of cosmic quarantine
so that we can never actually visit each
other and there's just so the distances
are so vast but thinking
that there's somebody else out there and
that maybe they're wondering the same
things that we are or maybe they figure
it out more than we have or maybe they
are behind us and they are just you know
don't know anything beyond their own
planet I don't know but we're laying
down on the grass and they're part yes
night without light pollution looking
back at you I would I would love that
that to me there it would be such a
satisfaction sack thinking about
thinking about them and I have a real
love for them I mean I don't know that
they exist I don't have any way to
communicate with them but I think about
them as really like our like our fellow
travelers in this universe and I really
I really think often about the fact that
we aren't alone yeah exactly
I'm so happy that you bring that up
regarding the most beautiful thing it is
no light pollution looking up at the sky
at the Stars is awe-inspiring it's
inspiring it's Eagle dwarfing yes it
just makes you really feel the vastness
of everything and I really like how you
took us to the perspective of thinking
about the other brethren and sistren
across the universe or even even just
even our galaxy sure to hopefully not
have that cosmic quarantine so that we
can make a loving connection across the
skies across the the deep sense you
don't see in movies you know oftentimes
that connection is very hostile we
vision we look at other civilizations as
being very hostile to our interests
they're all flying around right although
in contact to the Carl Sagan novel which
was made into a great film that wasn't
so I mean they were here to help us they
wanted to give us a road map to using
wormholes and advancing our knowledge of
basically being able to travel
throughout the cosmos so that's how I
would like to think about that but you
know even if they're not I would still
love them I don't
you know I would still love them because
I think they're made from what we are
made of that we may not share a common
genetic ancestor in the way that all of
us on earth do but you know as the
saying goes they're made from star stuff
also like the stars that comprise our
bodies are the stars that are the same
stars comprising their body is - correct
and then the difference might be
carbon-based or maybe there's silicon
based maybe they don't have any DNA at
all I don't know but if they're
conscious of anything they're existing
in this universe yes and they're
contemplating something maybe it's where
their next meal will come from who knows
if they even eat I don't know maybe they
just grow to synthesize I don't know we
are doing but if they're conscious of
anything I feel a real sense of
solidarity with them um I love that and
I think that that's that's an that's an
insanely important part about
recognizing that all seven and a half
billion of us are in the same tribe yeah
because it shouldn't take seeing an
alien to know that we are all one so
your answer so initially we had the list
of simulation questions sometime in the
early fall of 2017 and we sent them out
to all of our you know good friends that
we thought were you know global leaders
that we wanted to hear their answers to
and Paul answered the question are we
alone in the cosmos
and it's up on our it's up on our
website because it's such a funny answer
with what a waste of space that would be
it would be a tremendous waste of space
now of course the universe is under no
obligation to be an efficient use of
space obviously but it would be pretty
remarkable to think about the vastness
of the universe and then on this one
tiny little pale blue dot to use the
Sagan expression that's where although
everything is like I mean it's it's a
very self aggrandizing view obviously to
think like that
but I suspect that you know people like
Copernicus and Galileo helped us to
recognize that we aren't to the center
of the physical universe
and I do think that humanity will come
to recognize soon that we aren't in the
center of the moral universe either yeah
that others matter to that other species
matter as well yes and we're undergoing
kind of like a Copernican revolution in
not in terms of the physical universe
but in terms of our own ethical universe
and we consider as being worthy of being
within that circle of moral concern yes
it used to be that the only beings
inside of that circle more concern maybe
our family or our tribe and then you
expand it out and now you're talking
about maybe your nationality or your
religion and then you get out to being
to the point where today where a lot of
people would say oh well it doesn't
matter what your race or nationality or
religion or sexual orientation if if
you're Homo sapiens you're in the circle
and I'd suggest that's good
and many others would suggest that's
good but we can go further and if you
can feel pain if you're conscious of
anything then you have interests in
matter and we ought to consider those
interests and put that within our circle
of moral concern and that's why in the
same way that I would have loved for
those theoretical aliens circling other
suns out there I feel that way about
non-human animals here on earth - that
they're just here travelling on this
little watery rock going around our star
in the same way that you and I are and
they didn't have to be here either they
were born and we're gonna arise and go
away like that I mean
a you know from the grand perspective
we're here for the blink of an eye right
and so you know I think about you know
there is this type of solidarity that we
should feel with these other beings who
happen to be traveling that on this path
at the same time that we are and I think
about that for the chickens and the pigs
and the cows but also for the whales and
even the rats and other animals who are
here with us yeah exactly and I in
effect in a way I mean I think in the
past people have generally viewed
animals as being here for us and I think
generally speaking in the future we may
view them as not being here merely for
us with being here with us and that's a
radically different way to look at
things but I think that for so long we
have viewed animals merely as
commodities to be exploited by command
mood for whatever whim we want whether
its food or cord there or even something
as trivial as our own amusement I mean
think about the fact that we've
tormented wild animals and beaten them
into submission to perform in circuses
for our entertainment I mean that's
something that you know that is hard to
even imagine that we ever considered
acceptable zoos yeah
and so in the future though I think that
we'll have a healthier view of animals
and frankly a healthier view of
ourselves because it doesn't do us many
favors to think of ourselves as the apex
of all creation as the Lords who second
serve as tyrants over everybody else I
think a humbler view of ourselves is
probably healthier for us not only more
accurate but healthier for us to overly
healthier for us yeah and the ego
dwarfing with the Stars and all that
good stuff will help us get there and I
actually just want to say I had a one of
my friend showed me a photo of him at a
at a zoo in Disney and it was a massive
open zoo it wasn't closed at least but
it showed me the photo of gorilla from
far away and I just took I took tonight
Izu m-- and I zoomed and I zoomed on the
gorillas face you know still high enough
fidelity for me to look at the gorillas
eyes and the grill was looking right at
the car that was moving and in the look
on that gorilla was like
was like that was I was kind of like I
see what I see what's going on yeah I
recognize you
yeah and you know you have to ask
yourself like you know what crime did
that gorilla commit to be incarcerated I
mean for us to go gawk yeah I mean it's
it's really incredible now you know in
some cases for animals who are extremely
endangered and there's new habitat left
for them it's one thing but most animals
in captivity don't fall under that
category yeah this is this is so amazing
what we've covered let's do arena
computer simulation huh a lot of smart
people certainly think so I it's hard to
argue against I don't know if we are I
really wish that the creator of that
simulation might try to intervene for
our benefit because it doesn't look like
she he or it is doing that and what
would the creator of the simulation be
would would to you to you what would
that look like
who knows maybe it's like some fourth
graders science project I mean it could
be anything I mean it doesn't I mean it
to us I mean we are so little we're so
finite we're so frail I mean it's hard
for us even to imagine it I mean I I
frankly don't know I mean I I think
about it and what it might be like but
it could just be like some kids science
experiment some alien kids science
experiment who created us to see what
would happen so I I do hope that the
intervention of a program or simulator
or whoever this being is that could have
manifested what we exist in I hope that
the intervention is benign I but I am
potentially beneficial and but but at
the same time if even if there isn't one
it's probably the the coolest
experiment ever doctor did because the
lucien of these these these thinking
species that can contemplate something
like simulation theory and then seeing
how they work together if they blow
themselves up if not their proximity to
the star all these variables that can be
found yeah yeah so you just just think
about it like math and physics and
variables that can be tweaked and then
the the mass of the planet its proximity
the star how bright the star is how the
evolution actually occurred on the
planet what if they're carbon-based life
if their DNA coded life and then things
like the asteroid colliding 65 million
years ago enabling us to actually evolve
right so all these variables and they're
so fun to be able to tweak and then
those variables are changed like you
said when you look up at night at the
stars those variables are changed for
the other rock orbiting the star and
then for the other Rock and yeah yeah
it's pretty remarkable to think that
evolution has produced an animal that
can know evolution that that is a
remarkable thing or even to think about
the stars produced an animal that can
contemplate the stars and they know what
they're made of and I mean that is a
mind-boggling thing to contemplate it
yes and I hope that conversations like
this can really drive more people to
think in this way amazing evolution and
stars and we are now able to think about
them that this happened and now we're
able to think about them if we can get
more people the premise of what we're
doing with simulation so that we can get
more people to have these
thought-provoking conversations and try
and build the future together
yeah well one of the things that I am
impressed about your work by Alan is
that a lot of people were very good at
pointing out what problems are not as
many people are as good as trying to
theorize and talk about what solutions
there might be and it's very easy to
identify problems but being a what my
friends Oh while calls a solution arey
somebody who looks for solutions
I love that so yeah so I was a great
person she runs the Institute for Humane
education she's done a number of TEDx
talks that I recommend but solution area
is a term that she coined for people who
look for solutions to problems not just
those who identify problems and I think
of you as a solution area and trying to
examine not just what are the problems
well what can we actually do about it
can we actually do yeah
and how can we do together with all of
the different leaders across industries
with all the different unique
perspectives across places in the world
because that will then amplify the
creative creativity from all the
different journeys I think of you as a
solution areas well I really like that
word thanks for thanks for teaching us
that that's it that's a crucial point is
identify the the multivariable
multivariate problem and then also have
a deep desire to converse with people
about the solutions yeah so amazing Paul
Shapiro this has been a pleasure it's my
honor Alan we can find clean me across
Amazon you want to listen off everywhere
that you get books but if you want to
easily get it just go to clean meat calm
and you can see all the places you can
look you can buy it you can check it out
I have a TEDx talk on the topic as well
but just go to clean meat calm and you
can check out everything about the book
and the topic exactly and then make sure
when you go through make sure to give it
a nice you know give it a nice highlight
as you read right make sure you're
writing down key points and make sure
you're trying to you know one of our
previous simulations recently we had
Chester Santos a us memory champion who
was teaching us about once you once you
go through the process of taking the
note make sure to visualize the know
your mind add new senses to it so that
you can really retain that information
yeah you can create a little clean meat
memory palace a clean meat memory palace
that was perfectly said and enjoin us um
Paul Shapiro on Twitter at Paul H
Shapiro at Paul Shapiro and all these
links will be in the bio as well thank
you guys for tuning in if you guys had a
fun time if you guys found this content
useful please do give us a like give us
a comment down below subscribe share the
content with other people let us know
your thoughts about it and join us on
patreon you get great benefits like
being able to ask our guests question
you give benefits like access to live
events ahead of time access like being
able to join the community join the
conversation as at a deeper level we
have a bunch of different reward tiers
go check it out and the moral
satisfaction of knowing that you're
contributing to good in the world thank
you thank you we greatly appreciate that
we have we have this nice studio space
that we need to maintain now and be able
to provide for a safe and comfortable
environment for our guests a big shout
out to our producer and director Ron
Vargas he's been doing an amazing job
with us and thank you very much Paul
this has been an absolute pleasure
Allan it's mine thank you very much
thank you
[Music]